during the four realms princess Clara
saw service amazing talk to me about
just this magical day of being your big
debut on the big screen yes it's crazy
I'm not acting in the film I'm acting
through my movement but not with words
yet so yeah you know I think it's just
it's a special story for the ballet
world this is a very different story
although we borrowed from the Nutcracker
so I think that audiences are going to
be charmed certainly by misty and the
beautiful dancing and by McKenzie and
her journey through the looking-glass so
to speak the new rendition of the
Nutcracker picks up after the loss of
Clara's mother and the sugarplum fairy
played by Keira Knightley has all the
deeps ballet cows distillery all around
discovered and mother ginger played by
Helen Mirren is a force to be reckoned
with is it mother gingers now evil is
that what are the surprises that we have
in store
well I don't want to spoil but there's a
couple of really really exciting twists
and turns in this film that I think you
guys are gonna really like mother chin
just started this war don't you know
it's dangerous I very much enjoyed
working with all of the cars I also got
to do a scene with Dame Helen Mirren our
queen and that was a huge moment for me
yeah she tried to put me off when it was
my single by pulling faces and that was
amazing she's a dame she's a day maybe
she still behaves like a teenage girl on
set which I love
I think they give to be the Mouse King
was one of the most magical gifts I've
ever received and it's the gift that
keeps on giving
the Nutcracker in the four realms has
some fresh faces telling an old
Christmas classic through a new lid this
is my first actual film as a yeah as a
character they really hit home to me
because I'm from Memphis and I'm a part
of this show with my old ballet company
back when I was taking ballet there for
three years and I always played the
Mouse King Annette shows so that energy
that that was you know that just
transfer of energy and how Disney just
casted me as a mouse king it was it was
unbelievable and soldier Philip is still
as Noble as before he's cheeky he's
charming but he's still got his naive
character but he's still got his smarts
about him so you can't mess with Philip
it's time Saint the kingdom first memory
of the Nutcracker as a child well I went
to see The Nutcracker as a child I
actually was quite into ballet I did a
ballet class with my sister once my
father then stopped me doing ballet and
told me that I should do karate instead
and I was slightly devastated I'll be
seeing your dance moves in this film I
was so excited when they said we'd love
you to be in the Nutcracker and I was
like amazing tell me which dances I'm
doing and they said that I'm not dancing
so there's no dancing for me in this
film which is a tragedy because I
offered every day I said I could dance
at this point and they said no we just
want you to do your dialogues
I've literally played every role but I
would definitely say that like Clara was
it's my favorite within the ballet but
being the ballerina friend class is also
that's version
[Music]